[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
March 8th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal although tax preparation
software programs have made it easier
for people to do their taxes themselves
some taxpayers are opting to tack on the
additional expense of enlisting a
professional to either answer tricky
questions or handle their tax return
altogether but when is using a tax Pro
necessary and what should you look for
in a tax Pro Wall Street Journal
personal finance reporter Ashley Ebling
joins us with more hey Ashley thanks so
much for being with us nice to be here
so ashlea I don't know if anybody
actually looks forward to doing their
taxes well the IRS estimates the average
time all Americans spend on taxes is 13
hours at a cost of 250 dollars
including both those who file through
prepare and on their own so it's a big
time commitment for individual filers
with business income like
self-employment income reported on
Schedule C the average burden is even
greater it's 25 hours at a cost of 530
dollars wow that's a lot and so
everyone's tax situation is different
but in what cases is just using tax
software enough well accountants say
usually someone with a straightforward
return can benefit from software some
examples would be a retiree with income
including a social security check a
pension check and maybe an annual
distribution from an individual
retirement account or it could be a
married couple where both spouses have
W-2 wage and tax statements and they
have limited Investments outside their
workplace retirement plans either of
those types of filers could use
commercials tax software without any
extra help in most cases all right so
the do-it-yourself software programs can
make things easy but we're seeing the
tax software companies offer for add-on
services including enlisting a tax
professional to answer tricky questions
what types of issues might fall into
that category so the growing complexity
of tax filing is definitely convincing
more Americans to pay someone for help
and that can be tax software companies
they'll have add-on programs where you
can ask basic tax questions and then
they also have add-on programs where you
can actually have a tax Pro do your
return for you from start to finish
those types of complex issues that might
require that would be working in
multiple States having restricted stock
units that vest we're selling a rental
property even taxpayers with
self-employment income may want paid
advice because it can involve higher
audit red flags such as excessive
business deductions or the home office
deduction so what about not using the
software and going to a tax professional
that might handle your entire tax return
so I talked to one woman who's an expat
in Canada she had done her taxes with
commercial software for over a decade
with no problem but then things just got
too complex and she picked the services
of an old school tax preparer there are
definitely times when that makes sense
they not only help you catch mistakes
but if you've been with them year over
year they get to know you and then they
know what questions to ask to really
make sure your return's right you know
Ashley whenever somebody does their
taxes or if somebody does it for them
there's always a concern a fear they're
going to get an audit letter in the mail
if a tax Pro does prepare your taxes is
that person responsible if there are any
errors so if they make an error they're
definitely responsible if you neglect to
give them a tax form say reporting
interest income on a bank account or
self-employment income from a side job
that's your mistake you're the one on
the hook the paid preparer basically is
responsible for substantive accuracy of
your return but you're ultimately
responsible for the accuracy of every
item on it and the taxpayer has to sign
the return the taxpayer has to sign it
under penalty of perjury and you
definitely want a tax Pro who is signing
your return that's a complete red flag
to walk away from if a taxpay error says
they won't sign your return all right so
if you're seeking out a tax professional
to help you prepare your Returns what
sorts of things should you check out in
terms of the person's credentials so the
basic thing they need is prepare a tax
identification number again if they
don't have a tax identification number
that's another red flag to walk away
that alone doesn't guarantee any level
of expertise though over 75 percent of
all return prepare penalties that the
IRS issued encounter year 21 were
assessed against non-credential
preparers so you want to look for
credentials in addition to that tax
identification number and those
credentials could be a lawyer a
certified public accountant or an
enrolled agent they have to pass
competency exams they satisfy continuing
education requirements and they're
subject to standards of conduct plus
they could represent you before the IRS
and the event of an audit or collections
proceeding now how about Beyond
credentials what else should people have
on their list one financial planner I
talked to said it was super important to
ask potential preparers about their core
practice so for example whether they
have small business or expat clients or
whatever your particular situation
involves that helps you make sure
they're a good fit and that they have
the right expertise to guide you in
addition there are things they should
ask you for so they should ask taxpayers
for your last tax return since they're
items that calorie forward that you
might not know about and that could be a
form 8606 if you did backdoor Roth
contributions could be lost carry
forwards or refunds applied to estimated
taxes and one last thing to look for is
whether a tax Pro only does tax return
or also does proactive tax planning
what's the difference well another
financial planner I talked to said the
danger is a lot of tax process file
returns and move on but you can really
use your tax return to help you make
financial planning moves that will put
you in a better position for the next
year and going forward all right that's
Wall Street Journal personal finance
reporter
thanks so much for being with us thank
you and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]